(audience cheering)
(upbeat electronic music)
- You know, whether you're
an extrovert or an introvert,
it still comes down to having quality.
You can be all blustery and
all charismatic and all around,
but if you have no depth, you
will lose in the long game.
If you're an introvert,
maybe your opportunities for attention
won't happen as quickly,
but the reality is
there is so much opportunity
to win if you have quality skills.
Hi.
- Gary?
- Yes.
- I'm (mumbles) assistant.
- How are you?
- I was like, "I see you on Instagram.
I know you're close."
- My man.
What's up, brother?
- Good to see you.
How are you?
- Good.
- This is David.
- Hi David
- The Rock
- [David] How are you?
- [Dwayne] How you doin', man?
- How you doin'?
- Doin' good, man.
- You guys are filmin'?
- Yeah.
- What season is this now?
- Four.
- It's been great?
- It's been fantastic.
Yeah, it's been great.
(camera clicking)
- Love it dude, I gotta get dressed.
Always a pleasure.
- Always good to see you.
Give me a hug.
- Alright, buddy.
- Thank you.
- Gotta hit it.
Yeah! Bobby Babbin.
- I think Babbin, you know
it's just kind of like--
- [Man With Backpack] Why
does this shit not work?
- [Gary] Ain't got the key now?
- Hey, my fault.
- [Gary] No worries.
- Thought you guys had it.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Bobby Babbin sounds like the kind of--
If you say it slowly like Bobby Babbin.
It sounds like a good
country kind of like.
- [Man With Backpack] Oh yeah.
- I'm Bobby Babbin from Tallahassee.
If you want my Bobby Babbin beef jerkey.
Actually, you know what?
We should start a brand
right now, right now.
Bobby Babbin's beef jerkey.
- [Man] Oh my god, it would work.
- Of course it would work.
I'm involved.
Hey guys.
How are you?
- [Woman] Good, how are you?
- Good.
- [Man At Desk] Surprise visit?
Yeah.
I'm just gonna start coming
a hell of a lot more.
- Okay, cool.
- Nice fuckin' hoody.
- James is on that side in an office.
He's visiting.
- Orsini?
- Yeah.
- Awesome
- Pretty serious conversation.
- You're very serious.
Good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- How you doing, man?
- Good.
- Instagram.
Sorry to interrupt your
regularly scheduled programs,
but I'm here with my man James Orsini,
C.O.O. of VaynerMedia.
- This is not a ten pound deck
left on the corner of somebody's desk
that is not actionable.
This is meaningful, actionable plans.
What would you say the
minimum-size business
should be that's gonna be able afford it?
- Three million in revenue.
- Three million in revenue?
If you are up to three million in revenue
and very quickly like, "Oh
fuck. How did this happen?
I'm selling on Amazon or Instagram.
How do I not be caught by being just stuck
on just Amazon and
Instagram in three years
where I lose my business?"
Or if you've been running a business
and it's been in the
same place for the last
two, four, six, seven years.
I like the way you positioned it.
We're gonna position it that way, right?
- Yeah.
- Meaning.
What are we doing?
- Meaningful growth,
unlocking meaningful growth.
- Unlocking meaningful growth.
- By the way, the model, just
to give you guys a sense,
the model is instead of
charging you a million.
Call it what it is.
Instead of charging you
$700,000 a month, kind of thing,
or $70,000 a month, it's kind
of like a three month thing.
Charge a couple hundred thousand,
but we get to share a little bit
in the upside of the profit.
So we have vested interest.
We want to force ourselves to give a shit.
- Absolutely.
- So anyway, James will
give you all the details.
I just wanted to jump on.
We were literally just reviewing
and I was like, "Holy shit,
this is gonna be fuckin' amazing.
I'm going on live."
I was like, I literally
couldn't wait until Monday.
It is a big deal.
I have a feeling a lot of
people will be writing Medium
and LinkedIn posts of like
how I grew my business
from three to ten million.
- Yeah.
- In 24 months.
- It will be a picture of you.
Pretend you're now me.
That's you and you'll be with Orsini like.
That's how it's gonna happen.
Very excited about it.
I'm just massively committed
to blow it out of the water for you.
I'm very confident we can.
We've obviously vetted a lot of people
to be the right first choices
and we just know you're it for us
and we're gonna deliver for you.
- [Speaker On Phone] Thank you.
For us, it is very exciting
and we're fuckin' ready to go to town
and to learn, man.
Seriously, even just the
two days that I spent there
on the four deeds,
the kind of information
I got from your team
was fucking insane.
And I came back
and we started implementing
all this shit immediately
and we started seeing
all these fucking results
and it was like, "Holy."
Like the 60 second club,
when I sat down with Andy,
he gave me the breakdown.
He was like, "Do you know why we do that?"
And I'm like, "Well, it's a
cool little like give-away."
He's like, "No, dude. Let
me explain it to you."
He's like, "You need your own."
So we came back immediately the next day
and I said, "Guys, check this out.
This is what we fuckin' do."
And the interaction that we got,
the impressions in the first hour alone
off of just that one piece of information
was fuckin' mind-blowing.
We're like, "Holy shit, that's
why he said to do what I do."
So anyway, dude, I'm
just so fuckin' excited
and we're ready to learn all this stuff
and really grow the business with you.
Especially the way that you
have it organized, Gary,
as a partnership and it's
based off of profits.
- Right, because we're
gonna give a shit, right?
We're gonna make sure you get paid back
the money you give us.
I mean it's a no lose situation
for you, if we do it right.
- [Speaker On Phone] That's exactly right.
It's like a true fucking partnership
and that's why we're like,
"This is incredible."
We really see, it's a huge opportunity.
The value is like insane.
We're honestly, thank you.
We're very appreciative to
be part of this fuckin' thing
and we're gonna work our balls off hard.
- I can't wait for that.
- We're already goin' hard,
we're gonna go harder.
- I can't wait brother.
I appreciate you.
I'm lookin' forward to it.
Do you guys have the contract signed
and the kick-off meeting?
Where you guys at?
- [Speaker On Phone] Where
we're at right now is
I'm waiting.
Basically I got the email from
Dennis, the congratulations
and he's gonna send the paperwork over.
I told him we're anxious to get it goin',
we're ready to sign.
He said he's waiting on your schedule
to get the kick-off meeting going
that we can head out there
and get things moving.
- Love it, alright, I'll get to them.
Thanks, brother.
Talk to you soon, bye.
Goin' to the meet-up (mumbles), excuse me.
Goin' to the case risk sneaker drop,
the pop-up shop in L.A.,
London, and Toronto soon.
Only 600 pairs.
People already got them this morning
flipping them on the bay,
which I think is rad.
Love the hustle.
Only 600 pairs.
My prediction's a thousand dollars a pair
for crushing it five times,
New York Time's best selling.
We'll have several people there?
Should be a lot of fun.
Looking forward to meet and greet.
Q and A?
Should be good, should
be really, really good.
Not yet, I'm gonna be
there in like 20 minutes.
Why, are you around?
I'm flabbergasted if somebody
wants to do something
or accomplish something
that they would give up
after three weeks, three months,
heck even three years at times.
Now look, there's a very
fine line between delusion
that you're good at something
and actually being good at something.
(crowd cheering)
What up, what up?
- Motherfuckers in town
- Good to see you, brother.
- And I keep the hustle live.
Everybody make noise.
(crowd cheering).
- Congratulations.
- Thank you, fantastic.
- Give me one second.
We feel better now.
Crazy to see it in real life.
Die on your own sword,
baby, die on your own sword.
Your lack of patience is killing you.
Don't justify your
dreams, execute on them.
Big ups.
Super fired up to see all of
you here in L.A. come through.
Here in L.A. come through.
You guys ready?
(crowd cheers)
Every day, every week, why
we get some sort of traction
that we can be excited.
Maybe I wasn't getting a lot of views,
but I would get an email
from somebody who said
they got them too wide
or I would have a customer come in
and reference an episode.
I think people under estimate small wins.
They're so focused on
getting to a million views,
a million followers,
they forget about how special it is
to have a thousand followers.
First of all, big shout
out, thank you for the love.
Second of all, the number one advice
for young entrepreneurs is
self awareness and patience.
Know who the fuck you are
and then close your eyes for 10 years
and execute against it
and then pop your head up.
You're fuckin' young,
that's your advantage.
Stop over-thinking it, just do.
Do, do, do, be patient.
Do shit that you're good at or you love,
one of the two.
I mean I'm blown away by
people who poo-poo the notion
of ten thousand views, like it's nothing.
It's extraordinary.
Your grandparents most likely
never had ten thousand people
listen to their opinions in their lives,
let alone on a single video.
I think perspective is what gave me
the ability to keep moving.
One fuckin' life, do something about it.
Do something about it.
Listen, it's as simple as this.
Going through this whole fuckin' line.
It's just about believing.
Like the fact that I'm helping
people believe in themselves
blows my fuckin' face off.
Whether it's me or somebody else,
I have my mom and I'm
trying to do it for you.
It's really simple.
It's fuckin' binary.
You either think you can
fuckin' do this or you don't.
And the fact that I for some reason
am helping a bunch of you get
there, it makes me real happy.
But if I'm not, go find that thing
that absolutely fuckin' gets you there
because if you do not believe in yourself,
you have zero fuckin' chance
and if you do believe in yourself,
you have every fuckin' chance
to live it the way you want to live it.
So listen, if I'm not doin' it for you,
get the fuck out of here.
Go find a book, a parent,
a fuckin' long lost high school friend,
I don't give a fuck.
Find the thing that
makes you fuckin' believe
'cause that's the thing
that's fuckin' working.
I just understood that I had something
and I felt that I could fight through.
I was enjoying the process.
I wasn't doing it to become rich,
so that wasn't making me impatient.
And so just kind of old
school, brick by brick,
brick by brick and 12
years later you look up
and you've got a building.